[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you please
[Music]
never played that long
well thank you all very much and uh
good afternoon
uh vice president harris
and uh first gentleman
actually the second gentleman but you're
really my first gentleman
and uh ambassadors members of congress
uh thank you all for being here today
i think it's a pretty big day
just a few months ago i'll welcome
i welcome president anisto
al finland and the prime minister
anderson of sweden to the white house to
demonstrate the strong support the
united states
had for finland and sweden's decision to
apply for membership
in nato
and
two proud and independent countries each
with a long tradition a long tradition
of non-alignment exercising their
sovereign right to make their own
decisions about their own security
and uh responding to the will of their
citizens following the democratic
processes they have choosing to join
nato
it was and is a watershed moment i
believe in the alliance
and uh for the greater security
stability not only of europe and the
united states but of the world and today
we take another important step
toward bringing sweden and finland in
nato
in just a few minutes i'm going to sign
the u.s instrument of ratification
making the united states the 23rd ally
to approve sweden and finland's
membership to the strongest
most powerful defensive alliance in the
history of the world
i've just gotten off the phone with both
the president and the prime minister
they send their best
offer my congratulations on the enormous
progress thus far
together we committed that the united
states finland and sweden would continue
to remain vigilant against any threats
to our shared security and deter any
confrontation and confront any
aggression or threat of aggression that
might come up
and i urge the remaining allies to
complete their own ratification progress
as quickly as possible
for more than seven decades a strong
united nato
has been the foundation of american
security not just in europe but quite
frankly the basis of our security around
the world
it's how we've led the world together
with those nations that share our vision
and even more importantly our values
it's critical now to deter threats
before they harm our people our allies
and our interests
you know
it's how we address instability and
aggression
with allies at our side amplifying
amplifying the capacity to respond
effectively
sweden and finland
and sweden and finland have strong
democratic institutions
strong militaries and strong and
transparent economies
they'll meet every nato a crime
requirement we're confident of that
and we will make and make our alliance
stronger and we'll make america and the
american people safer in the process
that's why the united states senate gave
their advice and consent to sweden and
finland's membership with overwhelming
support
95 votes in favor
near a near record pace
this year we're celebrating significant
bipartisan steps that can make our
country stronger and enhance our ability
to lead the world
we're showing the world the united
states of america can still do big
things
this nearly unanimous bipartisan random
ratification sends another important
message the united states is committed
the united states is committed to the
transatlantic alliance
together with our allies and partners
we're going to write the future we want
to see the future we want to see
and in a moment when putin's russia has
shattered peace and security in europe
when autocrats are challenging the very
foundations of a rule-based order the
strength of the transatlantic alliance
and america's commitment to nato
is more important than it ever been
that's why in june and madrid
at a pivotal nato summit all 30 nations
came together to invite finland and
sweden to apply
it was a display of allied unity
allied strength and allied resolve
proof that nato's door remains open to
countries in europe that share our
values and that meet the high standards
of our alliance
putin thought he could break us apart
when this all started he believed he
could break us apart in my view weaken
our resolve
instead he's getting exactly what he did
not want he wanted the finalization of
nato
but he's getting the natoization of
finland along with sweden
[Applause]
seeking to join nato finland and sweden
are making a sacred commitment
that an attack against one is an attack
against all
it's article 5 of the washington treaty
and the core the very core of our
alliance
and our allies committed to article 5
and is stronger than ever that
commitment
the only time in history article 5 has
been invoked
was on 9 11
when the united states was attacked and
all our allies rallied to our side
the united states will never forget that
and we will never fail on our pledge
to defend every every every inch of nato
that's why together with our allies
we're taking steps to reinforce nato's
eastern flank
and strengthen our deterrence against
any threats of aggression
toward the alliance
you know
and we're going to be better able to
meet the new challenges of a changed
european security environment
with two strong reliable
highly capable
new allies in the high north
you know nato was formed out of the
wreckage of world war ii as we all know
where war
you know it had
look just be straight about it
wars have repeatedly riven the continent
engulfed the world in conflicts
and
and there's no way to avoid that if it
were not together
nato laid a new foundation
for lasting peace and security
and through more than seven decades as
follows
nato has proved the indispensable
alliance committed to europe whole
free and at peace
today
we see all too clearly haneda remains an
indispensable alliance for the world of
today and the world of tomorrow
our alliance is closer than ever
it is more united than ever
and when finland
and sweden
bring the number of allies to 32
will be stronger than ever stronger than
ever
and this will benefit all our people
all of our people
now i'm going to go over that table
there and sign a u.s instrument of
ratification communicating the support
of the united states for finland and
sweden's membership in nato and thank
you all for being here and i want to ask
the ambassadors whether they're willing
to come up and stand with me while i
sign
okay
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
okay here we go
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
attorney general garland tell you about
the trump parade
do you agree with the fbi
[Music]
wow
[Music]